[Music]
it is not worth telling this story of
mine
at least not worth writing told indeed
as i have sometimes been called upon
to tell it to a circle of intelligent
and eager faces
lighted up by a good after dinner fire
on a winter's evening
with a cold wind rising and wailing
outside
and all snug and cozy within it has gone
off
though i say it who should not in
different well
but it is a venture to do as you would
have me
pen ink and paper are cold vehicles for
the marvelous
and a reader decidedly a more critical
animal than a listener
if however you can induce your friends
to read it after nightfall
and when the fireside talk has run for a
while on thrilling tales of shapeless
terror
in short if you will secure me the malia
temper of fandy
i will go to my work and say my say with
better heart
well then these conditions presupposed i
shall waste no more words
but tell you simply how it all happened
my cousin tom ludlow and i studied
medicine together
i think he would have succeeded had he
stuck to the profession
but he preferred the church poor fellow
and died early
a sacrifice to contagion contracted in
the noble discharge of his duties
for my present purpose i say enough of
his character when i mention
that he was of a sedate but frank in
cheerful nature
very exact in his observance of truth
and not by any means like myself
of an excitable or nervous temperament
my uncle ludlow tom's father while we
were attending lectures
purchased three or four old houses in
anger street
one of which was unoccupied he resided
in the country
and tom proposed that we should take up
our abode in the unteneted house
so long as it should continue on let a
move which would accomplish the double
end of settling us nearer alike to our
lecture rooms and to our amusements
and of relieving us from the weekly
charge of rent for our lodgings
our furniture was very scant our whole
equipage remarkably modest and primitive
and in short our arrangements pretty
nearly as simple as those of a bivouac
our new plan was therefore executed
almost as soon as conceived
the front drawing room was our sitting
room i had the bedroom over it
and tom the back bedroom on the same
floor which nothing could have induced
me to occupy
the house to begin with was a very old
one
it had been i believe newly fronted
about 50 years before
but with this exception it had nothing
modern about it
the agent who bought it and looked into
the titles for my uncle
told me that it was sold along with much
other forfeited property
at chichester house i think in 1702
and had belonged to sir thomas hackett
who was lord mayor of dublin and james
the second
time how old it was then i can't say
but at all events it had seen years and
changes enough to have contracted all
that mysterious and saddened air
at once exciting and depressing which
belongs to most old mansions
there had been very little done in the
way of modernizing details
and perhaps it was better so for there
was something queer and bygone in the
very walls and ceilings
in the shape of doors and windows and
the odd diagonal sight of the chimney
pieces
in the beams and ponderous cornices not
to mention the singular solidity of all
the woodwork
from the banisters to the window frames
which hopelessly defied disguise and
would have emphatically proclaimed their
antiquity
through any conceivable amount of modern
finery and varnish
an effort had indeed been made to the
extent of papering the drawing rooms
but somehow the paper looked raw and out
of keeping
and the old woman who kept a little dirt
pie of a shop in the lane
and whose daughter a girl of 2 in 50 was
our solitary handmaid
coming in at sunrise and chastely
receding again
as soon as she had made all ready for
tea in our state apartment
this woman i say remembered it when old
judge horrix
who having earned the reputation of a
particularly hanging judge
ended by hanging himself as the
coroner's jury found
under an impulse of temporary insanity
with a child skipping rope
over the massive old banisters
entertaining good company with fine
venison and rare old port
in those halcyon days the drawing rooms
were hung with gilded leather
and i dare say cut a good figure for
they were really spacious rooms
the bedrooms were wainscoted but the
front one was not gloomy
and in it the coziness of antiquity
quite overcame its somber associations
but the back bedroom
with its two queerly placed melancholy
windows
staring vacantly at the foot of the bed
and with the shadowy recess to be found
in most old houses in dublin
like a large ghostly closet which from
congeniality of temperament
had amalgamated with the bed chamber and
dissolved the partition
at night time this alcove as our maid
was want to call it
had in my eyes especially sinister and
suggestive character
tom's distant and solitary candle
glimmered vainly into its darkness
there it was always overlooking him
always itself
impenetrable but this was only part of
the effect
the whole room was i can't tell how
repulsive to me
there was i suppose in its proportions
and features
a latent discord a certain mysterious
and
indescribable relation which jarred
indistinctly upon some secret
sense of the fitting and the safe and
raised indefinable suspicions and
apprehensions of the imagination
on the whole as i began by saying
nothing could have induced me to pass a
night alone in it
i had never pretended to conceal from
poor tom my superstitious weakness
and he on the other hand most
unaffectedly ridiculed my tremors
the skeptic was however destined to
receive a lesson
as usual here we had not been very long
in occupation of our respective
dormitories
when i began to complain of uneasy
nights and disturbed sleep
i was i suppose the more impatient under
this annoyance
as i was usually a sound sleeper and by
no means prone to nightmares
it was now however my destiny instead of
enjoying my customary repose
every night to sup full of horrors
after a preliminary course of
disagreeable and frightful dreams
my troubles took a definite form and the
same vision
without an appreciable variation in a
single detail
visited me at least on an average every
second night in the week
now this dream nightmare or infernal
illusion
which you please of which i was the
miserable sport
was on this wise i saw
or thought i saw with the most
abominable distinctness
although at the time in profound
darkness every article of furniture
and accidental arrangement of the
chamber in which i lay
this as you know is incidental to
ordinary nightmare
well while in this clairvoyant condition
which seemed but the lighting up of the
theater and which was to be exhibited
the monotonous tableau of horror
which made my nights insupportable my
attention invariably became
i know not why fixed upon the windows
opposite the foot of my bed
and uniformly with the same effect a
sense of dreadful anticipation always
took slow but sure possession of me
i became somehow conscious of a sort of
horrid but undefined preparation going
forward in some unknown quarter
and by some unknown agency for my
torment
and after an interval which always
seemed to me of the same length
a picture suddenly flew up to the window
where it remained fixed
as if by an electrical attraction and my
discipline of horror then commenced
to last perhaps for hours the picture
thus mysteriously glued to the window
panes
was the portrait of an old man in a
crimson flowered silk dressing gown
the folds of which i could now describe
with a countenance embodying a strange
mixture of intellect
sensuality and power but with all
sinister and full of malignant omen
his nose was hooked like the beak of a
vulture
his eyes large gray and prominent and
lighted up with a more than mortal
cruelty and coldness
these features were surmounted by a
crimson velvet cap
the hair that peeped from under which
was white with age
while the eyebrows retained their
original blackness
well i remember every line hue and
shadow of that stony countenance
and well i may the gaze of this hellish
visage was fixed upon me
and mine returned it with the
inexplicable fascination of nightmare
for what appeared to me to be hours of
agony
at last the [ __ ] he crew away then
flew the fiend who had enslaved me
through the awful watches of the night
and harassed and nervous i rose to the
duties of the day
i had i can't say exactly why but it may
have been from the exquisite anguish and
profound
impressions of unearthly horror with
which this strange phantasmagoria was
associated
an insurmountable antipathy to
describing the exact nature of my
nightly troubles to my friend and
comrade
generally however i told him that i was
haunted by abominable dreams
and true to the imputed materialism of
medicine
we put our heads together to dispel my
horrors
not by exorcism but by a tonic
i will do this tonic justice and frankly
admit that the accursed portrait
began to intermit its visits under its
influence
what of that was this singular
apparition
as full of character as of terror
therefore the creature of my fancy
or the invention of my poor stomach was
it in short
subjective to borrow the technical slang
of the day
and not the palpable aggression and
intrusion of an external agent
that good friend as we will both admit
by no means follows
the evil spirit who enthralled my senses
in the shape of that portrait
may have been just as near me just as
energetic
just as malignant though i saw him not
what means the whole moral code of
revealed religion regarding the dew
keeping of our own bodies
soberness temperance etc here is an
obvious connection between the material
and the invisible
the healthy tone of the system and its
unimpaired energy
may for what we can tell guard us
against influences which would otherwise
render life
itself terrific the mesmerist and the
electrobiologist will fail upon an
average with nine patients out of ten
so may the evil spirit special
conditions of the corporeal system
are indispensable to the production of
certain spiritual phenomena
the operation succeeds sometimes
sometimes fails
that is all i found afterwards that my
would-be skeptical companion had his
troubles too
but of these i knew nothing yet one
night for a wonder i was sleeping
soundly
when i was roused by a step on the lobby
outside my room
followed by the loud clang of what
turned out to be a large brass
candlestick
flung with all his force by poor tom
ludlow over the banisters
and rattling with a rebound on the
second flight of stairs
and almost concurrently with this tom
burst opened my door
and bounced into my room backwards in a
state of extraordinary agitation
i had jumped out of bed and clutched him
by the arm before i had any distinct
idea of my own whereabouts
there we were in our shirts standing
before the open door
staring through the great old banister
opposite at the lobby window
through which the sickly light of a
clouded moon was gleaming
what's the matter tom what's the matter
with you what the devil's the matter
with you tom
i demanded shaking him with nervous
impatience
he took a long breath before he answered
me and then it was not very coherently
it's nothing nothing at all did i speak
what did i say where's the candle
richard
it's dark i i had a candle
yes dark enough i said but what's the
matter what is it
why don't you speak tom have you lost
your wits what is the matter
the matter oh it is all over it must
have been a dream nothing at all but a
dream
don't you think so it could not be
anything more than a dream
of course said i feeling uncommonly
nervous
it was a dream i thought
he said there was a man in my room and
and i jumped out of bed and where's the
candle
in your room most likely i said shall i
go and bring it
no stay here don't go it's no matter
don't i tell you it was all a dream bolt
the door dick
i'll stay here with you i feel nervous
so dick like a good fellow light your
candle and open the window
i am in a shocking state i did as he
asked me and robing himself in one of my
blankets
he seated himself close beside my bed
everybody knows how contagious is fear
of all sorts
but more especially that particular kind
of fear under which poor tom was at that
moment laboring
i would not have heard nor i believe
would he have recapitulated just at that
moment
for half the world the details of the
hideous vision which had so unmanned him
don't mind telling me anything about
your nonsensical dream tom
said i affecting contempt really in a
panic
let us talk about something else but it
is quite plain that this dirty old house
disagrees with us both
and hang me if i stay here any longer to
be pestered with indigestion and
and bad nights so we may as well look
out for lodgings
don't you think so at once tom agreed
and after an interval said i have been
thinking richard
that it is a long time since i saw my
father and i have made up my mind to go
down tomorrow
and return in a day or two and you can
take rooms for us
in the meantime i fancied that this
resolution
obviously the result of the vision which
had so profoundly scared him
would probably vanish next morning with
the damps and shadows of night
but i was mistaken off went tom at peep
of day to the country
having agreed that so soon as i had
secured suitable lodgings
i was to recall him by letter from his
visit to my uncle ludlow
now anxious as i was to change my
quarters
it so happened owing to a series of
petty procrastinations and accidents
that nearly a week elapsed before my
bargain was made and my
letter of recall on the wing to tom and
in the meantime
a trifling adventure or two had occurred
to your humble servant
which absurd as they now appear
diminished by distance
did certainly at the time serve to whet
my appetite for change considerably
a night or two after the departure of my
comrade i was sitting by my bedroom fire
the door locked and the ingredients of a
tumbler of hot whiskey punch upon the
crazy spider table
as the best mode of keeping the black
spirits in white blue spirits and grey
with which i was environed at bay i had
adopted the practice
recommended by the wisdom of my
ancestors and kept my spirits up
by pouring spirits down i had thrown
aside my volume of anatomy
and was treating myself by way of a
tonic preparatory to my punch and bed
to half a dozen pages of the spectator
when i heard a step on the flight of
stairs descending from the attics
it was two o'clock and the streets were
as silent as a church yard
the sounds were therefore perfectly
distinct
there was a slow heavy tread
characterized by the emphasis and
deliberation of age
descending by the narrow staircase from
above
and what made the sound more singular it
was plain that the feet which produced
it were perfectly bare
measuring the descent with something
between a pound and a flop
very ugly to hear i knew quite well that
my attendant had gone away many hours
before
and that nobody but myself had any
business in the house
it was quite plain also that the person
who was coming down the stairs
had no intention whatever of concealing
his movements
but on the contrary appeared disposed to
make even more noise
and proceed more deliberately than was
at all necessary
when the step reached the foot of the
stairs outside my room
it seemed to stop and i expected every
moment to see my door
open spontaneously and give admission to
the original of my detested portrait
i was however relieved in a few seconds
by hearing the descent renewed
just in the same manner upon the
staircase leading down to the drawing
rooms
and then safter another pause down the
next flight
and so on to the hall once i heard no
more
now by the time the sound had ceased i
was wound up as they say
to a very unpleasant pitch of excitement
i listened
but there was not a stir i screwed up my
courage to a decisive experiment
opened my door and then a stentorian
voice bald over the banisters
who's there there was no answer but the
ringing of my own voice
through the empty old house no renewal
of the movement
nothing in short to give my unpleasant
sensations a definite direction
there is i think something most
disagreeably disenchanting in the sound
of one's own voice under such
circumstances
exerted in solitude and in vain
it redoubled my sense of isolation and
my misgivings increased on perceiving
that the door
which i certainly thought i had left
open was closed behind me
in a vague alarm lest my retreat should
be cut off
i got again into my room as quickly as i
could where i remained in a state of
imaginary black aid
and very uncomfortable indeed till
morning
next night brought no return of my
barefooted fellow lodger
but the night following being in my bed
and in the dark
somewhere i suppose about the same hour
as before
i distinctly heard the old fellow again
descending from the garrets
this time i had had my punch and the
morale of the garrison was consequently
excellent
i jumped out of bed clutched the poker
as i passed the expiring fire
and in a moment was upon the lobby
the sound had ceased by this time the
dark and chill were discouraging
and guess my horror when i saw or
thought i saw
a black monster whether in the shape of
a man or a bear
i could not say standing with its back
to the wall
on the lobby facing me with a pair of
great greenish
eyes shining dimly out now i must be
frank
and confess that the cupboard which
displayed our plates and cups stood just
there
though at the moment i did not recollect
it
at the same time i must honestly say
that making every allowance for an
excited imagination
i never could satisfy myself that i was
made the dupe of my own fancy in this
matter
for this apparition after one or two
shiftings of shape
as if in the act of incipient
transformation began
as it seemed on second thoughts to
advance upon me
in its original form from an instinct of
terror rather than courage
i hurled the poker with all my force at
its head
and to the music of a horrid crash made
my way into my room
and double locked the door then in a
minute more
i heard the horrid bare feet walk down
the stairs till the sound ceased in the
hall
as on the former occasion if the
apparition of the night before
was an ocular delusion of my fancy
sporting with the dark outlines of our
cupboard
and if its horrid eyes were nothing but
a pair of inverted teacups
i had at all events the satisfaction of
having launched the poker with admirable
effect
an in true fancy phrase knocked its two
daylights into one
as the co-mingled fragments of my tea
service testified
i did my best to gather comfort and
courage from these evidences
but it would not do and then what could
i say of those horrid bare feet
and the regular [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] which
measured the distance of the entire
staircase
through the solitude of my haunted
dwelling and at an hour when no good
influence was stirring
confound it the whole affair was
abominable
i was out of spirits and dreaded the
approach of night
it came ushered ominously in with a
thunderstorm and dull torrents of
depressing rain
earlier than usual the streets grew
silent and by 12 o'clock
nothing but the comfortless patterning
of the rain was to be heard
i made myself as snug as i could i
lighted two candles instead of one
i for swore bed and held myself in
readiness for a sally candle in hand
for i was resolved to see the being if
visible at all
who troubled the nightly stillness of my
mansion
i was fidgety and nervous and tried in
vain to interest myself with my books
i walked up and down my room whistling
in turn marshall and hilarious music
and listening ever and on for the
dreaded noise
i sat down and stared at the square
label on the solemn and reserved looking
black bottle
until flanagan and co's best old malt
whiskey grew into a sort of subdued
accompaniment
to all the fantastic and horrible
speculations which chased one another
through my brain
silence meanwhile grew more silent and
darkness darker
i listened in vain for the rumble of a
vehicle or the dull clamor of a distant
row
there was nothing but the sound of a
rising wind which had succeeded the
thunderstorm that had traveled over the
dublin mountains quite out of hearing
in the middle of this great city i began
to feel myself
alone with nature and heaven knows what
besides
my courage was ebbing punch however
which makes beasts of so many made a man
of me again
just in time to hear with tolerable
nerve and firmness
the lumpy flabby naked feet deliberately
descending the stairs again
i took a candle not without a tremor
as i crossed the floor i tried to
extemporize a prayer
but stopped short to listen and never
finished it
the steps continued i confess i
hesitated for some seconds at the door
before i took heart of grace and opened
it when i peeped out the lobby was
perfectly empty
there was no monster standing on the
staircase and as the detested sound
ceased
i was reassured enough to venture
forward nearly to the banisters
horror of horrors within a stair or two
beneath the spot where i stood the
unearthly tread smote the floor
my eye caught something in motion it was
about the size of goliath's foot
it was gray heavy and flapped with a
dead weight from one step to another
as i am alive it was the most monstrous
grey rat i ever beheld or imagined
shakespeare says some men there are
cannot abide a gaping pig
and some that are mad if they behold a
cat i went well nigh
out of my wits when i beheld this rat
for laugh at me as you may
it fixed upon me i thought a perfectly
human expression of malice
and as it shuffled about and looked up
into my face almost from between my feet
i saw i could swear it i felt it then
and know it now the infernal gaze and
the accursed countenance of my old
friend and the portrait
transfused into the visage of the
bloated vermin before me
i bounced into my room again with a
feeling of loathing and horror i cannot
describe
and locked and bolted my door as if a
lion had been at the other side
damn him or it cursed the portrait in
its original
i felt in my soul at the rat yes the rat
the rat i had just seen
was that evil being in masquerade and
rambling through the house upon some
infernal night lark
next morning i was early trudging
through the miry streets
and among other transactions posted a
peremptory note recalling tom
on my return however i found a note from
my absent chum
announcing his intended return the next
day
i was doubly rejoiced at this because i
had succeeded in getting runes
and because the change of scene and
return of my comrade
were rendered specially pleasant by the
last night's half-ridiculous
half-horrible adventure i slept
extemporaneously in my new quarters in
diggs street that night and next morning
returned for breakfast to the haunted
mansion
where i was certain tom would call
immediately on his arrival
i was quite right he came and almost his
first question referred to the primary
object of our change of residence
thank god he said with genuine fervor on
hearing that all was arranged
on your account i am delighted as to
myself i assure you that no earthly
consideration could have induced me ever
again to pass a night in this disastrous
old house
confound the house i ejaculated with a
genuine mixture of fear and detestation
we have not had a pleasant hour since we
came to live here
and so i went on and related
incidentally my adventure with the
plethoric old rat
well if that were all said my cousin
affecting to make light of the matter
i don't think i should have minded it
very much
i but it's i its countenance my dear tom
urged i
if you had seen that you would have felt
it might be anything but what it seemed
i'm inclined to think the best conjurer
in such a case would be an able-bodied
cat
he said with a provoking chuckle but let
us hear your own adventure
i said tartley at this challenge he
looked uneasily around him
i had poked up a very unpleasant
recollection
you shall hear it dick i'll tell it to
you he said
be god sir i should feel quite queer
though telling it here
though we are too strong a body for
ghosts to meddle with just now
though he spoke this like a joke i think
it was a serious calculation
our maid was in a corner of the room
packing our cracked delft tea and dinner
services in a basket
she soon suspended operations and with
mouth and eyes wide open
became an absorbed listener tom's
experiences were told nearly in these
words
saw it three times dick three distinct
times and i'm perfectly certain it meant
me some infernal harm
i was i say in danger in extreme danger
for if nothing else had happened my
reason would most certainly have failed
me
unless i had escaped so soon thank god i
did escape
the first night of this hateful
disturbance i was lying in the attitude
of sleep in that lumbering old bed
i hate to think of it i was really wide
awake though i had put out my candle
and was lying as quietly as if i had
been asleep and although accidentally
restless
my thoughts were running in a cheerful
and agreeable channel
i think it must have been two o'clock at
least when i thought i heard a sound in
that
that odious dark recess at the far end
of the bedroom
it was as if someone was drawing a piece
of cord slowly along the floor
lifting it up and dropping it softly
down again in
coils i sat up once or twice in my bed
but could see nothing so i concluded it
must be mice in the wainscot
i felt no emotion greater than curiosity
and after a few minutes ceased to
observe it
while lying in this state strange to say
without at first a suspicion of anything
supernatural
on a sudden i saw an old man rather
stout and square
in a sort of roan red dressing gown and
with a black cap on his head
moving stiffly and slowly in a diagonal
direction
from the recess across the floor of the
bedroom
passing my bed at the foot and entering
the lumber closet at the left
he had something under his arm his head
hung a little at one side
and merciful god when i saw his face
tom stopped for a while and then said
that awful countenance
which living or dying i never can forget
disclosed what he was
without turning to the right or left he
passed beside me
and entered the closet by the bed's head
while this fearful and indescribable
type of death and guilt was passing
i felt that i had no more power to speak
or stir than if i had been myself a
corpse
for hours after it had disappeared i was
too terrified and weak to move
as soon as daylight came i took courage
and examined the room
and especially the course which the
frightful intruder had seemed to take
but there was not a vestige to indicate
anybody's having passed there
no sign of any disturbing agency visible
among the lumber that strewed the floor
of the closet
i now begin to recover a little i was
exhausted
and at last overpowered by a feverish
sleep i came down late
and finding you out of spirits on
account of your dreams about the
portrait
whose original i am now certain
disclosed himself to me
i did not care to talk about the
infernal vision
in fact i was trying to persuade myself
that the whole thing was an illusion
and i did not like to revive in their
intensity the hated impressions of the
past night
or to risk the constancy of my
skepticism by recounting the tale of my
sufferings
it required some nerve i can tell you to
go to my haunted chamber next night
and lie down quietly in the same bed
continued tom
i did so with a degree of trepidation
which i am not ashamed to say
a very little matter would have sufficed
to stimulate to downright panic
this night however passed off quietly
enough as also the next
and so too did two or three more i grew
more confident
and began to fancy that i believed in
the theories of spectral illusions
with which i had first vainly tried to
impose upon my convictions
the apparition had been indeed
altogether anomalous
it had crossed the room without any
recognition of my presence
i had not disturbed it and it had no
mission to me
what then was the imaginable use of its
crossing the room in a visible shape at
all
of course it might have been in the
closet instead of going there
as easily as it introduced itself into
the recess without entering the chamber
in a shape discernible by the senses
besides how the deuce had i seen it it
was a dark night
i had no candle there was no fire and
yet i saw it as distinctly
and coloring an outline as ever i beheld
human form
a cataleptic dream would explain it all
and i was determined that a dream it
should be
one of the most remarkable phenomena
connected with the practice of mendacity
is the vast number of deliberate lies we
tell ourselves
whom of all persons we can least expect
to deceive
in all this i need hardly tell you dick
i was simply lying to myself
and did not believe one word of the
wretched humbug yet i went on as men
will do
like persevering charlatans and
impostors who tire people into credulity
by the mere force of reiteration
so i hope to win myself over at last to
a comfortable skepticism about the ghost
he had not appeared a second time that
certainly was a comfort
and what after all that i care for him
and his queer old toggery and strange
looks
not a fig i was nothing the worst for
having seen him and a good story the
better
so i tumbled into bed put out my candle
and cheered by a loud drunken quarrel in
the back lane
went fast asleep from this deep slumber
i awoke with a start
i knew i had had a horrible dream but
what it was i could not remember
my heart was thumping furiously i felt
bewildered and feverish
i sat up in the bed and looked about the
room
a broad flood of moonlight came in
through the curtainless window
everything was as i had last seen it and
though the domestic squabble in the back
lane was unhappily for me
a lade i yet could hear a pleasant
fellow singing on his way home
the then popular comic ditty called
murphy delaney
taking advantage of this diversion i lay
down again
with my face towards the fireplace and
closing my eyes did my best to think of
nothing else but the song
which was every moment growing fainter
in the distance
twas murphy delaney so funny and frisky
stepped into a sabine shop to get his
skin full
he reeled out again pretty well lined
with whiskey
as fresh as a shamrock as blind as a
bull
the singer whose condition i dare say
resembled out of his hero
was soon too far off to regale my ears
anymore
and as his music died away i myself sank
into a doze
neither sound nor refreshing somehow the
song had got into my head
and i went meandering on through the
adventures of my respectable fellow
countrymen
who on emerging from the shabeen shop
fell into a river
from which he was fished up to be sat
upon by a coroner's jury
who having learned from a horse doctor
that he was dead as a doornail
so there was an end returned their
verdict accordingly
just as he returned to his senses when
an angry altercation and a pitched
battle between the body and the coroner
winds up delay with due spirit and
pleasantry
through this ballad i continued with a
weary monotony to plod
down to the very last line and then
decapo
and so on in my uncomfortable half sleep
for how long i can't conjecture
i found myself at last however muttering
dead as a doornail
so there was an end and something like
another voice within me
seemed to say very faintly but sharply
dead dead dead and may the lord have
mercy on your soul
and instantaneously i was wide awake and
staring right before me from the pillow
now will you believe it dick i saw the
same accursed figure
standing full front and gazing at me
with its stony and fiendish countenance
not two yards from the bedside
tom stopped here and wiped the
perspiration from his face
i felt very queer the girl was as pale
as tom
and assembled as we were in the very
scene of these adventures
we were all i dare say equally grateful
for the clear daylight and the resuming
bustle out of doors
for about three seconds only i saw it
plainly
then it grew indistinct but for a long
time there was something like a column
of dark vapor
where it had been standing between me
and the wall and i felt sure that he was
still
there after a good while this appearance
went too
i took my clothes downstairs to the hall
and dressed there with a door half open
then went out into the street and walked
about the town till morning
when i came back in a miserable state of
nervousness and exhaustion
i was such a fool dick as to be ashamed
to tell you how i came to be so upset
i thought you would laugh at me
especially as i had always talked
philosophy
and treated your ghosts with contempt i
concluded you would give me no quarter
and so kept my tale of horror to myself
now dick you will hardly believe me when
i assure you that for many nights after
this last experience
i did not go to my room at all i used to
sit up for a while in the drawing room
after you had gone up to your bed
and then steel down softly to the hall
door let myself
out and sit in the robin hood tavern
until the last guest went off
and then i got through the night like a
century pacing the streets till morning
for more than a week i never slept in
bed i sometimes had a snooze on a form
in the robin hood
and sometimes a nap in a chair during
the day but regular sleep i had
absolutely none
i was quite resolved that we should get
into another house
but i could not bring myself to tell you
the reason and i somehow put it off from
day to day
although my life was during every hour
of this procrastination
rendered as miserable as that of a felon
with the constables on his track
i was growing absolutely ill from this
wretched mode of life
one afternoon i determined to enjoy an
hour's sleep upon your bed
i hated mine so that i had never except
in a stealthy visit every day to unmake
it
lest martha should discover the secret
of my nightly absence
entered the illomond chamber
as ill luck would have it you had locked
your bedroom and taken away the key
i went into my own to unsettle the bed
clothes as usual
and give the bed the appearance of
having been slept in
now a variety of circumstances concurred
to bring about the dreadful scene
through which i was that night to pass
in the first place i was literally
overpowered with fatigue
and longing for sleep in the next place
the effect of this extreme exhaustion
upon my nerves resembled that of a
narcotic
and rendered me less susceptible than
perhaps i should in any other condition
of ben
of the exciting fears which had become
habitual to me
then again a little bit of the window
was open a pleasant freshness pervaded
the room
and to crown all the cheerful son of day
was making the room quite pleasant
what was to prevent my enjoying an
hour's nap here
the whole air was resonant with the
cheerful hum of life
and the broad matter of fact light of
day filled every corner of the room
i yielded stifling my qualms to the
almost
overpowering temptation and merely
throwing off my coat and loosening my
cravat
i lay down limiting myself to half an
hour's doze and the unwanted enjoyment
of a featherbed
a coverlet and a bolster
it was horribly insidious and the demon
no doubt
marked my infatuated preparations dolts
that i was
i fancied with mind and body worn out
for wand of sleep
and an arrear of a full week's rest to
my credit that such measure as half an
hour's sleep in such a situation was
possible
my sleep was death-like long and
dreamless
without a start or fearful sensation of
any kind
i waked gently but completely it was as
you have good reason to remember
long past midnight i believe about two
o'clock
when sleep has been deep and long enough
to satisfy nature thoroughly
one often awakens in this way suddenly
tranquilly
and completely there was a figure seated
in that lumbering old sofa chair
near the fireplace its back was rather
towards me
but i could not be mistaken it turned
slowly round
and merciful heavens there was the stony
face
with its infernal lineaments of
malignity and despair
gloating on me there was now no doubt as
to its consciousness of my presence
and the hellish malice with which it was
animated for it arose
and drew close to the bedside there was
a rope about its neck
and the other end coiled up it held
stiffly in its hand
my good angel nerved me for this
horrible crisis
i remained for some seconds transfixed
by the gaze of this tremendous phantom
he came close to the bed and appeared on
the point of mounting upon it
the next instant i was upon the floor at
the far side and
in a moment more was i don't know how
upon the lobby
but the spell was not yet broken the
valley of the shadow of death was not
yet traversed
the abhorred phantom was before me there
it was standing near the banisters
stooping a little and with one end of
the rope around its own neck
was poising a noose at the other as if
to throw over mine
and while engaged in this baleful
pantomime it wore a smile
so sensual so unspeakably dreadful that
my senses were nearly overpowered
i saw and remember nothing more until i
found myself in your room
i had a wonderful escape dick there's no
disputing that
an escape for which while i live i shall
bless the mercy of heaven
no one can conceive or imagine what it
is for flesh and blood to stand in the
presence of such a thing
but one who has had the terrific
experience
dick a shadow has passed over me a chill
has crossed my blood and marrow
and i will never be the same again never
dick never
our handmaid a mature girl of two and
fifty as i have said
stayed her hand as tom's story proceeded
and by little and little drew near to us
with open mouth and her brows contracted
over her little beady black eyes
till stealing a glance over her shoulder
now and then she established herself
close behind us
during the relation she had made various
earnest comments in an undertone
but these and her ejaculations for the
sake of brevity and simplicity
i have emitted in my narration it's
often i heard tel aviv
she now said but i never believed it
rightly till now
though indeed why should not i does not
my mother down there in the lane
no queer stories god bless us beyond
telling about it
but you ought not to have slept in the
back bedroom she was loathe to let me be
going in and out of that room even in
the daytime
let alone for any christian to spend the
night in it for sure she says it was his
own bedroom
whose own bedroom we asked in a breath
why his the old judges judge horrocks to
be sure
god rest his soul and she looked
fearfully round
amen i muttered but did he die there
die there no not quite there she said
sure was knotted over the banisters he
hung himself the old sinner
god be merciful to us all and was nodded
in the alcove they found the handles of
the skipping rope cut off
and the knife where he was settling the
cord god bless us to hang himself with
it was his housekeeper's daughter on the
rope my mother often told me
and the child never throve after and
used to be starting up out of her sleep
and screeching in the night time
with dreams and frights that came at her
and they said how it was the spirit of
the old judge that was tormenting her
and she used to be roaring and yelling
out to hold back the big old fellow with
a crooked neck
and then she'd screech oh the master the
master he's stamping at me and beckoning
to me
mother darling don't let me go and so
the poor creature died at last
and the doctor said it was water on the
brain for it was all they could say
how long ago was all this i asked
oh then how would i know she answered
but it must be a wonderful long time ago
for the housekeeper was an old woman
with a pipe in her mouth and not a tooth
left and better nor 80 years old when my
mother was first married
and they said she was a real buxom
fine-dressed woman when the old judge
came to his end
and indeed my mother's not far from 80
years old herself this day
and what made it worse for the unnatural
old villain god rest his soul
to frighten the little girl out of the
world the way he did was what was mostly
thought and believed by everyone
my mother says how the poor little
creature was his own child
for he was by all accounts an old
villain every way and the hanginess
judge that ever was known in ireland's
ground
from what you said about the danger of
sleeping in that bedroom
said i i suppose there were stories
about the ghost having appeared there to
others
well there was things said queer things
surely
she answered as it seemed with some
reluctance and why would not there
sure was it not up in that same room he
slept for more than 20 years
and was it not in the alcove he got the
rope ready that done his own business
at last the way he done many a better
man's in his lifetime
and was not the body lying in the same
bed after death
and put in the coffin there too and
carried out to his grave from it in
pether's churchyard
after the corner was done but there was
queer stories my mother has them all
and how one nicholas spite got into
trouble on the head of it
and what did they say of this nicholas
spite i asked
oh for that matter it's soon told she
answered
and she certainly did relate a very
strange story which so piqued my
curiosity
that i took occasion to visit the
ancient lady her mother
from whom i learned many very curious
particulars
indeed i am tempted to tell the tale but
my fingers are weary and i must defer it
but if you wish to hear it another time
i shall do my best
when we had heard the strange tale i
have not told you we put one or two
further questions to her about the
alleged spectral visitations
to which the house had ever since the
death of the wicked old judge
been subjected no one ever had luck in
it
she told us there was always cross
accidents sudden deaths and short times
in it
the first that took it was a family i
forget their name but at any rate there
was two young ladies in their papa
he was about 60 and a stout healthy
gentleman as you'd wish to see at that
age
well he slept in that unlucky back
bedroom and god between us and harm
sure enough he was found dead one
morning half out of the bed
with his head as black as a slow and
swelled like a pudding
hanging down near the floor it was a fit
they said
he was as dead as a mackerel and so he
could not say what it was
but the old people was all sure that it
was nothing at all but the old judge god
bless us
that frightened him out of his senses
and his life together
some time after there was a rich old
maiden lady took the house
i don't know which room she slept in but
she lived alone
and at any rate one morning the servants
going down early to their work
found her sitting on the passage stairs
shivering and talking to herself
quite mad and never a word more could
any of them or her friends get from her
ever afterwards
but don't ask me to go for i promised to
wait for him
they never made out from her who it was
she meant by him
but of course those that knew all about
the old house were at no loss for the
meaning of all that had happened to her
then afterwards when the house was let
out in lodgings
there was mickey byrne that took the
same room with his wife and three little
children
and sure i heard mrs byrne myself
telling how the children used to be
lifted up in the bed at night
she could not see by what means and how
they were starting and screeching every
hour
just all as one as the housekeeper's
little girl that died till at last one
night poor mickey had a drop in him the
way he used to now and again
and what do you think in the middle of
the night he thought he heard a noise on
the stairs
and being in liquor nothing else would
do him but he must go himself to see
what was wrong
well after that all she ever heard of
him was himself saying oh god
and a tumble that shook the very house
and there sure enough he was lying on
the lower stairs under the lobby
with his neck smashed double under him
where he was flung over the banisters
then the handmaiden added i'll go down
to the lane and send up joe gabby to
pick up the rest of the things
and bring all the things across to your
new lodgings
and so we all sallied out together each
of us breathing more freely i have no
doubt
as we cross that illowman threshold for
the last time
now i may add this much in compliance
with the immemorial usage of the realm
of fiction
which sees the hero not only through his
adventures but fairly out of the world
you must have perceived that what the
flesh blood and bone hero of romance
proper
is to the regular compounder of fiction
this old house of brick wood and mortar
is to the humble recorder of this true
tale i therefore relate as in duty bound
the catastrophe which ultimately befell
it
which was simply this that about two
years subsequently to my story
it was taken by a quack doctor who
called himself baron doolsdorf
and filled the parlor windows with
bottles of indescribable horrors
preserved in brandy
and the newspapers with the usual grand
eloquent and mendacious advertisements
this gentleman among his virtues did not
reckon sobriety
and one night being overcome with much
wine he set fire to his bed curtains
partially burned himself and totally
consumed the house
it was afterwards rebuilds and for a
time an undertaker established himself
in the premises
i have now told you my own and tom's
adventures together with some valuable
collateral particulars
and having acquitted myself of my
engagement i wish you a very good night
and pleasant dreams
you